il mio libro storie paurose a scuola di
misteri e ora disponibile in libreria e
online metti alla prova il suo coraggio
leggilo e accumula tutti i punti della
challenge nel libro più solida stare il
sasso grandissimi si
fa forte casa il titolo di gioco i
signori progetto che sono scorso via
volta raggiunto i 10 mila mi piace
avremmo fatto la terza parte lo scorso
video ha superato ionici
se anche questo video super e 10 mila mi
piace si starà anche la quarta parte
spalleggiate parlerò ad ormai vi stiamo
subito la nostra casa al tesoro vediamo
se raccoglierlo più facili a pupo vita
mentale allora riprendiamo eravamo
rimasti siamo in una situazione
siamo centro i piccolini e le cose sono
giganti vediamo vediamo vediamo quanti
ne trovo sbrighiamoci dobbiamo superare
evitare che ho già trovato un
pupazzo di neve quindi io ho
120 pop hit pure non avete visto gli
altri episodi andate poi a vederli
perché è troppo divertente questa caccia
al tesoro dei pop hit e ovviamente come
sempre prendete i pop corn qualche teso
bere qualcosa do maggiore mettetevi
comodi soprattutto qualcosa da mangiare
la mia mente ecco un po pit lane con
la valascia salirà sopra
vediamo se restano la sedia
vitale stare cento raccoglieremo vetta
ecco cosa
dovete stare 26 pop hit degli elfi
quanti pop hit dobbiamo prendere per
superare questo stage e devo ancora
prendere 5 che ce la faremo attori
spagnoli che ce la faremo trovare tutti
i cinque pop hit vediamo che altri stage
casco intanto salito sulla sono troppo
colpo gioco devi salire dalla sedia
figo
dei caduta film vediamo sicuramente c'è
qualche pop etico sobrero per motivo
io ti ho aiutato ora aiutami tu dimmi
dove sono i pochi credo di averne visto
uno su sulla cattedra o su un banco là
dietro ho visto anche uno sulla tv
andiamo a prendere quello della di
prendere quello della cattedra allora
dovrebbe essere qui
non è una carta di decreto sia un banco
sono salite sulla casa per zanetti obi e
un banco creato l'aspetta guarda dentro
ha detto della cattedra c'è il pof it
della pigrizia
sia la forma di bradipo e quando c'è
nient'altro però dunque d'acqua sopra
forse riesco a vedere chi è vero sopra
la tv c'è un po petto la domanda come ho
fatto a salire sopra la cattedra devi
sparire dallo zaino o fa non trovo altri
pop hit e non riesco a salire nella tv
ha un'idea userò errata che belle
ma quanto distanza mi sta allontanando
chi dopo chi è questa qui sulla tv
immagino dove ce n'è un altro po vicino
11 50 metri d'acqua forte quando prendi
avuto eco sopra
sul suo problema dov'è il compito
bellissimo dentro la gabbia del criceto
brava troppo pop hobbit criceto che
carino vedevo se c'è qualcos'altro qua
forse nella pianta o da passo però vedo
tutta la classe oltre al pop hit nella
tv da ne vedo altri voi mi vedete altri
chumba salire sulla tv allora proviamo a
segno questo
perché non pochissimi pochi sto
divertendo un po nella gabbia del
criceto
chiudiamo evitare dei
non facciamo girare per la roma ma
quello che stiamo facendo e io un'idea
ce a provà salire qua in questa mensola
e poi proprio andare il lato bravo belle
idee o prende armadio vediamo se c'e
qualcosa allora questo l'avevo già preso
io sì sono andato libro non sono sono
caduto non sono riuscito a vincere
qualcosa allora d'acqua
saltiamo qua
e poi no non mi dire che non c'è niente
un fa è stato inutile arrivare qua non
c'è niente l'ho anche io prima sono
fatto così è accaduto vediamo dentro
all'armadio qualcosa forse dentro
l'armadio hanno già controllato però mi
sembra di no c'è solo la pallina vip
accorsi sono riuscito a capire come fa
evitare che ha trovato uno vedo né
termosifone
il motore primo sito a trovare niente
davvero forse il termosifone diverso che
dentro termosifone ma non è il papa ha
ancora
preso pop il drago di drago ci manca
solo un po pitt che dovrebbe essere
quello non la tv o forse se ne
qualcun'altro nascosto sotto il banco
ovvero
non l'avevo visto quello rendiamo subito
se riusciamo a prenderla bra il pop hit
calcolatrice ed ora riusciamo a passare
o forse se ne volevano 126 no non mi
dire te l'ho detto ma lo dobbiamo
trovare con l'altro degli assolo 125.000
idratati vediamo sessione un altro oltre
a quello della tv perché quella relativo
è impossibile da prendere poi ho trovato
il passaggio potesse evitare la sosia
davis amico e qui praticamente ho
scoperto che dal controsoffitto si
arriva proprio sulla fino in fondo ce la
fa proviamo a trovare il modo vediamo
proviamo prof
se un altro fidget 15 o
addirittura a 127 arriviamo ad esso come
hai fatto a vedere questo buco nel mondo
volevo bravissimo perché ho visto che ce
n'era uno così sopra la tv non ci credo
le trovate
soffitto allora possiamo già passare
senza che io chiamo prendiamo anche
l'esatto e quello volevo prendere o farà
scendere e dunque se questo dobbiamo
buttarci sopra ecco sei riuscito però ci
credo se l'abbiamo fatta siamo
subito al prossimo
speriamo già un film più
cos'è
un deposito deposito della scuola la
loro io salgo qui intanto questo che
cos'è un garage sono tanti computer ho
già trovato un feed back non me ne
trovate il resto a mi devo inchinare qua
presa io l'ho trovato un osso di
computer invece presso presto troviamo
tutti i papi prima di evitare
allora vediamo quasi una scala questa di
questa era un po quando l'ho trovato un
po più a 128 e tu 129 per dare mi ha
superato tutto brad
pitt come hai fatto a stadi a casa oprah
ok sto totalizzare da scrivania vediamo
se c'è qualcosa qua non mi dire grazie a
niente
pensavo fosse un po btb
ecco le cose un po più
civetta che bene viviamo da pasta
provvediamo dove sono i pop hit
non vale niente
saltiamo fa nelle sedie
vediamo se c'è qualcosa qua
[Musica]
dietro a
questa forma di scrivania
presa
c'è scritto il tuo pc ha riscontrato un
problema deve essere riavviato
abbiamo bisogno di 133 fidget per
passare mancano solo 3 dai possiamo
farcela vediamo se c'è qualcosa come
vice sopra qui questa barra di ferro ok
poi dietro dietro al secondo monitor ce
n'è uno per
me manca solo due poi puoi scendere
andare in quelle scatole li scatola
questo bellissimo per dire dei pupi più
belle editore del gatto dai ci manca
solo un po pitt possiamo farcela
usiamo il radar ci aiutiamo a vicenda
stiamo avvicinando ci stiamo avvicinando
pochino pochino credo che sia proprio
qua l'altro pop hit sopra questa lampada
vediamo
un ventilatore
se riuscita ho visto qualcosa ho visto
qualcosa
fa caduta
o pitt si vieta
ora possiamo bastare ma prima aiutiamo
vita per favore prossima
si
ripete che evita camera trovare al
ritiro a prendere l'ultimo pit vediamo
che bobby desistono qua ho anche preso
la supervelocità
così vado ancora più veloce che bella
questa stellina
bellissimo eccoci
friggete arcobaleno finito il gioco
il ragazzo sappiamo che ce l'avresti
fatta rinascita dietro di me
raccoglierli di nuovo vediamo quanti
pubbliche abbiamo raccolto si può vedere
se guardate questi sono tutti i pop hit
che abbiamo raccolto
bellissimi a mano e mi mancano però in
realtà non è finita non lo sapete perchè
perchè c'è anche l'altro un gioco io
andiamo su mio caro pronti via ecco qua
non a caso di coppito questo adesso è
tema pasquale infatti vedete ho le
orecchie
ma siamo in una fattoria proprio da uomo
no dobbiamo sempre trovare i pooh pitt e
noah spera molto ben rubato l'uovo lo
stupro detto io ho preso il nome di
pasqua quindi hanno fatto desistere di
pasta in cui invece che trovare in pop
hit dobbiamo trovare le abbia fatto
qualche bello viene sira trovarle prima
passare il prossimo stage di euro 8 uova
di pasqua sei un debutto così rompo le
uova no vediamo se quando il posto c'è
qualche uovo forse ho salutato
io l'ho trovato uno in cantina per dopo
così puoi venire a freddo una retta
prendere quest'uovo tutta qua
ok preso tre muovere nuovo e con altro
uovo un ovetto verde ne mancano
pochissimi c'è uno sul tetto davvero il
prezzo è in me l'ha rubata
che bello rotto
mi mancherà solo due come fatta salire
su questo o un castello lì a fianco che
affido ecco un altro uomo rozzo che
carino me levante farò uno una porta
segreta qua presto andiamo a trovare ai
bambini
sempre tipo quella di scary teacher e
non c'è ecco che ci si deve aspettare
possiamo ora passare un prossimo stage
già otto le uova sono sei anno bisogna
prenderne atto
diamo pro risalire nel tetto forse c'è
qualcosa dall'alto prove della serie
shell questi un terrazzino
colleghi
che bella vari tavola dai fedeli e ora
andiamo al prossimo stesso vediamo più
che sospetta prossimo stage siamo nella
cittadina non porta nessuna macchina qua
a dobbiamo cercare nelle varie casette
allora che carino che mettono qua
che cairo ha già trovato l'uomo nell
armadio abbiamo qua sopra ora se c'è
qualcuno ma non abita nessuno in queste
casette le uova
questo non eletto vabbè essere un nuovo
non trovo è toccato a vero che come
vediamo in quest'altra casa che uova ci
sono e da non cedete qua o muori dal
piano di sopra per evitare coniglio da
nuovo e poi dietro nel camino lo stop è
piaciuto alla brace come facciamo a
prenderlo come si passano di qua dentro
da qui forse c'è una scala qualcuno è
sceso quindi forse dal tetto che nell
asta è vero proviamo a salire sul tetto
è come si fa a salire sul tetto bella
domanda è quasi il garage o le casse su
un altro nuovo con le impronte che caino
ehi qualcuno che sta chiudendo dentro
pace la cuccia del cagnolino c'è un
altro uovo che carino un tempo ma ci
vogliono per il prossimo stage trovato
ancora qua ra qua c'è un passaggio
segreto e diamo fu
servono 16 uova per info 16 ma io sono
solo 11
io qui ho trovato l'altra vicino questa
gip qui ok una macchina o eccolo che
carino io nel bianco p sopra questa casa
sia un pulsante vediamo cosa succede per
la copre tutto sia aperto botanico qua
dentro me ma mi mancano solo due uova
ecco la scala vitale da blue me come
come presto italia musica vino buttiamo
dice un altro uomo qui non c'è niente
è sparito eccolo che bello non si va da
nessuna parte in questo cammino ci manca
solamente un nuovo propria parte qua
gara l'ho capita no pure io se ho capito
bisogna saltare prima qui e poi
è un pregio luogo del camino
sentiamo fatto un po bruciacchiato per
tutto dal camino vanno pensavo anch'io
di bruciarmi in verità ora possiamo
passare al prossimo atteso vediamo che
faccio petto
prossimo stage per il prossimo stage ne
servono 24 tipo in un test ora sto
arrivando sta arrivando un ristorante si
mangia ovviamente
mettono i panini d'acqua che cosa e
scavolini
diciamo no travain incisivo ma noi
vogliamo le uova lamentano una nuova un
po
siamo finiti
eccola giusy un nuovo ma se volete che
continuiamo anche queste skype room
delle uova di sosta lasciate un bel mi
piace e ora mi lasciavo quattro
casalinghe sequi cliccare per vedere
inoltre altri video chat e su quella che
preferite